what says differentiate this weird log
function and then hits evaluate integral
so here's the whole function log on sec
+ tab they say differentiate that and
had to evaluate they give you a definite
integral this one ok so just off the
face so you will remember looking at
this right now when we you are
integrating last time we had an equal
sign cos tan but then for your
reciprocal functions we didn't really
have nice neat ones that come out okay
that's because they look really awful
like this it's a bit like when you're
integrating tan what's the integral of
tan easier that one it also has a
lawgiver log on the like on it's a
negative log cos x so this is a similar
kind of situation so it's differentiate
see what happens this is channel for a
log right so you've got this thing in
here as your inside function call F
right and so the derivative is just F
dash on F right so let's go turn by turn
one of the derivatives sec turns into no
second man yeah good then of course 10
pounds in two sec square that's f dash
need to divide by f ok so this actually
is quite a simple one because you can
see on the top you can factorize you can
take out a sec and that leaves you in
10x plus seconds which exactly the same
thing that you have in your denominator
right so that's why you can't slap and
you get sack alright so when they talk
about this is what it says in the
program the integrals that use the
relationship between integration and
differentiation here's what they mean if
i were to put these two i should put
them on the same line really okay this
derivative is equal to that and i'm
trying to work out this integral okay
i'm going to take the integral of both
sides with respect to is pleased to
limit
that's the wrong word okay so therefore
by integrate both sides what's going to
happen will the left hand side right
because it's a derivative of something
when i integrate I'm just going to end
up with that something in war within the
limits that I'm interested in right so
you see i'm integrating the left-hand
side with respect to X from north to
pine for okay and then what you have
here is a question okay you see I've
done the same thing to both sides that's
that's all logged on so now all that's
left is to evaluate right and this is
what I'm after over here so I'll put
this on the left-hand side and you got
log off this is my first phone log of
sick pie on for sec pine for the second
comes from college right so cause
platter for is 1 over 2 so you take the
reciprocal that's going to give you or
to write sec pine for 10 PI over 4 10
pound for a little easier that's 10 or
45 which is just one okay so there's my
second pint for cam phone book and you
don't need this first bracket ok there's
my upper boundary so i'll subtract the
lower boundary right which is log of now
sec all 0 sake of 0 that's one on cos 0
what's caused 0 it's just one so one on
one is on one then I've got tan 0 right
which is just 0 okay so yeah you've got
log of 1 here that's the log base e of
one right and you think okay this means
what power do I after a is e to either
power of something give me one and the
answer is 0 for this whole thing on the
right hand side disappears as well
tah-dah there you go that's all it is
all right evaluated often you'll get
things like this you have to
differentiate something and then go
backwards sometimes when you
differentiate you get saved for example
good my color so fun is just literally
right if we were two different [ __ ]
suppose there was a true out the front
artery simplified okay therefore if I
was not asked to integrate this okay
because this is not in the form that I
exactly want it it needed to their right
we just throw half out the front you're
used to this kind of thing to compensate
right so just be careful what you get as
a result after differentiating might not
be exactly the same as though what do
they want you didn't do great okay so
just take up account for it okay all
right I should get rid of because that's
wrong that's not what